today's one minute monday is give first
whenever you are going into any kind of
relationship in business try to give
first before focusing on yourself and
asking something here's a quick example
I was recently asked to join a
mastermind group for YouTube
entrepreneurs people who have successful
YouTube channels who are trying to grow
let's meet once a week help each other
with our channels and together we can
get some great ideas to continue to
explode and dominate the world and say
yes i'm in i got on the first kong
realized there wasn't really a structure
yet it was just starting up i had a lot
of experience mastermind groups so the
first thing i did was i shared my zucca
guide on how to create a mastermind
group assured that with them the next
thing i did was we started on the
founder and we spent the whole session
focusing on him and we've got the next
two weeks lined up with two of the other
members who could focus on them you know
I have burning issues I have things I
need help with I have questions that I
want to answer you know I need that
that's why I joined the group but I'm
focusing on them first because I know
when it comes to my turn I'm going to
get incredible value because I've set up
that relationship you want to do the
same thing with your business whenever
you're going into something new focus on
them first focus on giving focus on
getting them to like you know you trust
you so when you ask for something it's
not it's not this guy she's trying to
sell me on something's not this guy's
just trying to use me it's it's mutual
they'd like it they feel honored to be
able to help you out just like you've
helped them what I want you guys to do
is leave a comment below let me know how
you have given first how you have helped
people and how it came back to help grow
your business so we can all share I
learn from your success leave a comment
below thank you guys believe hi Raquel
English here with mermaid junkutv are
you on Evans newsletter subscription if
not you should be I read every single
one and you should too channel
you